this year's Midas list comes at a really
interesting time for venture capital
obviously with the market in turmoil and
with many businesses struggling some
people are very concerned about what the
impact of the coronavirus kovat 19 means
for the startup ecosystem and prevent
sure capital investing as a group starts
are coming to make really tough
decisions right now and to get through
the short term you know even companies
that still really believe in a huge long
term vision needs to survive the next
few months and so we've been seeing a
lot of layoffs a lot of furloughs
companies doing hiring freezes and you
know this is happening at really big
startups but also some small startups
too we've laid off 22 percent of our
workforce which was two hundred and
something people and then we have
furloughed an additional 11 percent of
our workforce and the total people that
were impacted by this is 435 either were
laid off of furloughed and then I'll see
you in addition to this everyone that's
in the team is also like you know
there's an element of shared burden and
shared sacrifice through reduction of
Valerie's reduction in salaries we've
seen analyst concerned that investment
will drop a lot in the next few months
now we haven't seen a huge downturn
necessarily yet pitchbook a start-up
tracker found that q1 was not really
that much of a drop but as the - list
comes out in April we are at an
interesting juncture where some people
believed that investing in the next few
months could drop off quite a bit and
startups will be in some sort of
Darwinian situation where the good ones
can be okay but the bad ones may get cut
loose in general we're telling people to
get to 18 to 30 months of runway if they
can and you know for those that needed
help to get there you know we have to
sort of go through every single one and
try to help them do that another
unexpected silver lining for companies
that do have a lot of cash or are
profitable is that this is the best
hiring season since 2008-2009 you know
there are a lot of companies that had to
cut not just fat but muscle they had to
cut deeply into their you know the
people who they really didn't want to
let go and those people are out there in
the job market in sort of a volume that
I don't think we've seen in more than 10
years many of the - no species actually
made their investments in the last
downturn if you look at uber you look at
Airbnb these are companies that came
sort of out of the down cycle of Oh 8 oh
9 and interestingly enough you know when
people were leaving business schools 10
years ago they didn't necessarily want
to go to Wall Street or to the big banks
after the financial crisis this is going
to catalyze like a lot of
entrepreneurship and a lot of innovation
like you know one of the things that you
know we've seen in the dot-com boom in
Boston 9/11 and then the Oh a crisis is
that many of our best companies were
born without out of that environment and
I you know we're not go to predict what
you know is around the corner with
specificity but I can pretty much
guarantee you that there'd be a lot of
people that are forced because they can
be daring and take on ambitious projects
because the opportunity cost is so low
now they're gonna be forced to go try
new things in a booming economy in
frothy times you can raise money on the
basis of a story on the basis of hope of
what you might be able to accomplish and
in harder times you're basing it on what
you've accomplished what you've done
what you're able to do and so from a
team perspective from a planning
perspective from a leadership
perspective all of those things are
suddenly very different and the the
founders who embrace that the startups
who understand the the concept behind
that those are the ones that that do
well in this type of scenario the
weirdest thing about all of this is that
some startups are sort of revived from
the dead and doing really well that we
would have thought were not that
interesting a few months ago I mean look
at blue a
which went public and was basically a
penny stock in January and is now one of
the top performing stocks of 2020 so far
like that was a company that had been
written off and all these mule-kick
businesses are doing way better like no
smart person bought in the fall of
nineteen that milk eight companies were
still the future and then there are
businesses that are really interesting
in cool businesses but depend on live
experiences and those businesses for
example are just getting completely
hammered in the short term right now so
we're in this really weird soupy
situation where I think you know no one
really knows the answers